Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Imagine that you are a film critic and you
are recording a video review of a movie, but
unfortunately you are not the best kind of
movie critic, and you record it before watching
the movie.
But here is the problem - you don’t really
know if it’s going to be any good.
So you record this.
So far so good.
Nothing too crazy going on here.
However, you go in, watch the movie, and it
turns out to be amazing.
So, what do we do if we don’t have time
to re-record the video?
Well, we grab this AI, type in the new text,
and it will give us this.
Whoa!
What just happened?
What kind of black magic is this?
Well, let’s look behind the person, on the
blackboard you see some delicious partial
derivatives, and I am starting to think that
this person is not a movie critic.
And of course, of course he isn’t, because
this is Yoshua Bengio, legendary machine learning
researcher.
And this was an introduction video where he
says this.
And, what happened is that it has been repurposed
by this new DeepFake generator AI, where we
can type in anything we wish, and out comes
a near-perfect result.
It synthesizes both the video and audio content
for us.
But we are not quite done yet.
Something is missing.
If the movie gets an A+, the gestures of the
subject also have reflect that this is a favorable
review.
So, what do we do?
Maybe add a smile there.
Is that possible?
Oh yes, there we go!
Amazing.
Let’s have a closer look at one more example
where we see how easily we can drop in new
text with this editor.
Now, this is not the first method performing
this task - previous techniques typically
required hours and hours of video from a target
subject.
So how much training data does this require
to perform all this?
Well, let’s have a look together!
Look, this is not the same footage copy-pasted
three times, this is a synthesized video output
if we have 10 minutes of video data from the
test subject.
This looks nearly as good, has fewer sharp
details, but, in return, this only requires
2.5 minutes.
And here comes the best part.
If you look here, you may be able to see the
difference.
And if you have been holding on to your papers
so far, now, squeeze that paper because synthesizing
this only required 30 seconds of video footage
of the target subject.
My goodness.
But we are not nearly done yet, it can do
more!
For instance, it can tone up or down the intensity
of gestures to match the tone of what is being
said.
Look.
So how does this wizardry happen?
Well, this new technique improves two things
really well, one is that it can search for
phonemes and other units better.
Here is an example, we crossed out the word
“spider” and wish to use the word “fox”
instead, and it tries to assemble this word
from previous occurrences of individual sounds.
For instance, the “ox” part is available
when the test subject utters the word “box”.
And two, it can then stitch them together
better than previous methods.
And surely this means that since it needs
less data, the synthesis must take a great
deal longer, right?
No, not at all, the synthesis part only takes
40 seconds.
And even if it couldn’t this so quickly,
the performance control aspect where we can
tone the gestures up or down, or add a smile
would still be an amazing selling point in
and of itself.
But no, it does all of these things quickly,
and with high quality at the same time.
Wow.
I now invite you to look at the results carefully,
and give them a hard time.
Did you find anything out of ordinary?
Did you find this believable?
Let me know in the comments below.
The authors of the paper also conducted a
user study with a 110 participants, who were
asked to look at 25 videos and say which one
they felt was real.
The results showed that the new method outperforms
previous techniques, even if they have access
to 12 times more training data.
Which is absolutely absolutely amazing, but
what is even better, the longer the video
clips were, the better this method fared.
What a time to be alive!
Now, of course, beyond the many amazing use-cases
of DeepFakes in reviving deceased actors,
creating beautiful visual art, redubbing movies,
and more, we have to be vigilant about the
fact that they can also be used for nefarious
purposes.
The goal of this video is to let you, and
the public know that these DeepFakes can now
be created quickly and inexpensively, and
they don’t require a trained scientist anymore.
If this can be done, it is of utmost importance
that we all know about it!
And beyond that, whenever they invite me,
I inform key political and military decision
makers about the existence and details of
these techniques to make sure that they also
know about these and using that knowledge,
they can make better decisions for us.
You can see me doing that here.
Note that these talks and consultations all
happen free of charge, and if they keep inviting
me, I’ll keep showing up to help with this
in the future as a service
to the public.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!